Okay, so as you can see that the candle closed at 9.30.
So now you will be looking for some sort of liquidity, okay?
So actually, you should be looking for liquidity
before 9.30, right?
And if it sweeps the liquidity and comes back,
and the market structure shift happens,
your entry must be after 9.30 AM, okay?
It can, for example, let me show you.
If there's liquidity, right?
And price sweeps off the liquidity at, let's say, 9.20 AM.
And then we have a market structure shift at 9.25, right?
And you have your entry, where is it?
Okay, you have your entry at here, right?
If the price goes into your entry zone before 9.30,
you will not be taking that trade, okay?
You just gotta follow these rules, okay?
I know what I'm saying.
You should avoid that trade at all costs.
But if the time is 9.30, right?
Past 9.30 AM, and it goes to your POI,
then you take that trade, boom.
So for this example, we have our candle closed at 9.30.
So where's the liquidity, guys?
I can see this huge swing high, right?
This is a clear, significant swing high that I can see.
So, and one more thing, guys,
you wanna look for the market structure,
okay, the overall direction of the market,
and you wanna take the trade in that direction.
So, as you can see, price is bearish at the moment.
And if I go zoom out a little bit more,
you can see that we are bearish.
And considering the, you know,
the situation of the world right now,
there's so much wars going on,
I would recommend that you only take shots for now,
because the trend, so you gotta just follow
the market structure, right?
If the market structure is bearish,
you only have to take a short position,
you only wanna be looking for a liquidity sweep
to the upside, okay?
And then you wait for Microsoft Shift
and you take your entry.
So as you can see at the 9.30 a.m.,
we have this candle, and if I play this through,
okay, so once the price is near my zone,
the liquidity zone, I will drop down
to the one minute timeframe,
and I will wait for a liquidity sweep.
So as you can see, price swept the liquidity.
Now I wanna wait for a market structure shift.
So let's see what happens.
And there you go, we have a market structure shift.
One more thing to note, guys, is when market structure shift
happens, it should happen with displacement,
and what I mean with displacement is,
let's say you have this, right?
And if price breaks the structure like this,
so let me show you, yep.
If, oh my God, this is a terrible trying,
but I hope you get the idea.
So if the price breaks the structure with,
you know, a very clumsy market structure,
there is no momentum in that move that breaks the structure,
then you will not be taking the trade
because when price came down,
it generated this liquidity, right?
And I would recommend that you don't take this trade
because there was no momentum,
there was no volume when the structure broke.
But if price breaks the structure, for example,
let me show you, if we have this structure, right?
And price breaks the structure with momentum,
like, for example, this.
If you see this, you gotta take your entry.
So as you can see, we have this huge candle,
and then we have some sort of wicks here
above, below the fair value gap and the water block.
And as you can see, we should broke the market structure.
Now, as you can see, there's some fair value gap around here.
So I would take my entry from the fair value gap.
You can take your entry from the auto block,
but sometimes you're gonna miss the trade.
So I would recommend that you only take your entries
from the fair value gap.
And you can see it was filled around here, right?
So we can take our entry from the remaining part,
or we can just take the entry from the original part.
So it's just gonna be fine.
And we put our stop loss right above the body of the candle,
or we can either put it to the high of the candle.
And for the take profit level,
we could go for this level right around here
because this is a significant liquidity level.
As you can see, this is a significant low, right?
And between this move, there are some fair value gaps.
So you can see we have this fair value gap,
and we have this fair value gap.
So you must be taking some partial profit,
so when the trade is in the play,
you should not be holding your trade.
And once some sort of structure is broken,
for example, the structure gets broken,
you're gonna go break even.
So this is very simple.
Once this structure breaks, you will go break even.
So let's see how this trade plays out.
So if I play this through,
we got our entry right here.
And if I play this through,
you can see that the price is going down,
and we hit our take profit level.
So that was an 8.42 risk to the World Trade.
Very, very excellent example.
I'm gonna give you guys a few more examples.
So, yeah.
Okay.